[Musique]
notre invité à occuper l'un des postes
les plus exposés de France peut-être
plus exposé encore que celui de
président de la République le genre de
poste où tout le monde croit mieux
savoir que vous le poste que nous sommes
près de 68 millions à occuper tous les
quatre ans oui vous l'avez compris notre
invité a été sélectionneur de l'équipe
de France de football pendant 6 ans il a
géré la pression de l'opinion la
pression des journalistes celle des
joueurs il a géré les polémiques les
critiques les scandales et il l'a fait
avec son style avec flegme avec ironie
parfois certains diront avec froideur ou
même avec mépris lui vous répondra qu'il
a été comme il est depuis toujours un
brin provoque un art revêche ça lui a
été beaucoup reproché et ils s'en est un
peu amusés mais qu'en a-t-il été avec
les responsables politiques a-t-il
affiché ce côté rebelle avec Jacques
Chirac ou Nicolas Sarkozy lorsque l'un
d'eux a décroché son téléphone pour lui
faire gentiment passer des messages
d'autorité ou de recadrage a-t-il reçu
d'ailleurs ce genre de coup de fil POS
toutes ces questions bienvenue dans un
monde un regard bienvenu Raymond
Domenech merci d'être avec nous au Dôme
tourno on est au Sénat alors c'est un
peu normal que je commence avec la
partie politique Jacques Chirac et
Nicolas Sarkozy ont-ils fait pression
sur vous lorsque vous étiez
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France je
sais que c'est beaucoup dit raconté mais
jamais jamais un coup de téléphone si
mais jamais de pression je n'ai jamais
de pression c'est c'était des ça avait
été des encouragements et que Monsieur
Chirac avec Monsieur Sarkozy je me
souviens il m'avait même invité à
déjeuner mais c'était pour sentir le
ce qui pouvait se passer mais jamais
pour me dire il faut faire si il faut
faire ça jamais
faussement amicale
non jamais j'ai beau chercher souvent je
me suis posé la question et ce qui m'ont
influencé d'une manière ou d'une autre
monsieur Chirac c'est sûr non Monsieur
Sarkozy dans les dans les discussions
non parce qu'on parlait pas des pas des
joueurs ils disaient pas il faut faire
jouir aussi celui-là il est bien
pourtant
tout le monde a compris les politiques
en particulier à quel point l'équipe de
France pouvait être fédératrice et même
disons-le un peu rentable sur le plan
politique l'équipe de France est un
objet politique et devenu un objet un
objet politique le sport est un objet
politique il y a les JO vous rendez
compte comment ça se passe c'est pas
anodin tous les sports mais le foot qui
a une place quand même dominante avec
les politiques oui c'est sûr ils savent
que ça ça mobilise les jeux du cirque on
y est les nouveaux gladiateurs c'est les
sportifs on est là et on fait des jeux
et du pain c'est nous on le connaît mais
on fait avec les politiques peuvent s'en
servir il s'en servent souvent à la
limite et je l'ai vécu ça quand ça va
pas et que tout d'un coup ils viennent
faire les redresseurs de tort j'ai eu
quelques ministres comme ça qui est tout
d'un coup sont apparus pour dire mais
c'est scandaleux mais c'est si mais
c'est là juste pour justifier moi j'en
ai eu deux deux qui se sont déchirés
anaïsna
de femmes voilà qui est à ce moment-là
sont fait la guerre entre elles sur le
dos du foot mais pour justifier une
morale
qu'elle nous représentait même pas alors
c'est intéressant que vous parliez de ça
parce que vous faites ma transition pour
illustrer cette intrusion quand même du
politique dans le foot français je
voudrais rappeler l'intervention de
Roselyne Bachelot peut-être pensiez voir
elle alors ministre de la Santé et des
Sports en audition à l'Assemblée
nationale après la faire un Elka et
l'incident de Nice nain je rappelle
quand même les faits pour ceux qui
auraient oublié ou ceux qui seraient
plus jeunes on est au Mondial de 2010 en
Afrique du Sud Anelka vous insulte en
privé ces mots sortent dans la presse
vous l'excluez scandale au sein de
l'équipe de France une partie des Bleus
en public ni en privé il y avait pas eu
d'insuffis et je le répète partout
d'ailleurs j'ai revu Nico on en discute
encore non il l'a peut-être dit des
trucs après quand j'étais pas là mais en
face de moi jamais et je le maintiens je
le dis je le répète en tout cas la
presse parle d'un fiasco sportif et
morale et le politique s'en mêle
audition à l'Assemblée donc de Roselyne
Bachelot je lis les propos de la
ministre j'ai vu des joueurs qui
fonctionnait en autarcie coupée de la
fédération et de leur équipe technique
j'ai vu un sélectionneur en difficulté
qui n'avait plus d'autorité sur ces
troupes la ministre qui rappelle ensuite
les mots qu'elle a utilisé face au bleu
là-bas en Afrique du Sud je laisse cite
toujours vous avez perdu la bataille de
la communication mais vous avez perdu
beaucoup plus que cela vous avez perdu
l'estime de la classe politique de la
presse du monde du sport des citoyens
des sponsors des jeunes c'est pour vous
un désastre je vous parle en tant que
mère avec le recul que vous avez
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous diriez que
le politique est allé trop loin
complètement
s'il y en a qui sont ridiculisés dans
cette affaire là c'est bien eux parce
que ça n'avait pas de sens n'avait pas
d'utilité d'ailleurs pour pour
l'anecdote je veux dire elle est venue
pour parler de solidarité et la première
chose qu'elle a faite elle a pris les
joueurs tout seul pour leur parler sans
en refusant que le staff en fasse partie
je déjà la solidarité elle l'avait elle
l'avait écarté j'ai trouvé ça pitoyable
ridicule qui n'avait aucun sens c'était
de l'OPP mécanismes politiques je veux
dire pour justifier quoi on sait pas
trop
ça concerne l'équipe de France alors du
coup tous les Français doivent être au
courant de tout et d'ailleurs
oui tout le monde doit être au courant
de tout mais de quoi je veux dire les
résultats sportifs on l'a vu on a été à
côté et encore à ce moment-là quand elle
était intervenus on pouvait encore se
qualifier donc elle est venue rajouter
de la pression à de la pression alors
que on avait le dernier match où c'était
encore faisable et jouable et on nous a
mis une telle pression normalement
c'était une affaire interne c'est sorti
parce que tous les médias des trucs mais
c'était même pas une affaire c'était un
événement de entre sportif qui arrive
dans un vestiaire ou des joueurs qui
sont repris par leur entraîneur bah
réagissent d'une manière ou d'une autre
mais vous qui rêviez d'être président de
la République comment comment vous vous
auriez gérer une telle affaire par
exemple
là c'est sportif ça reste sportif
c'était le président de la Fédération de
football de gérer c'est une ingérence
totale c'est ce qu'on reproche toujours
au nous entraîneurs aux dirigeants de
clubs c'est d'intervenir directement sur
les joueurs sans
en écartant l'entraîneur j'ai un
document à vous proposer du passé
d'ailleurs
livré par nos partenaires les Archives
nationales il s'agit du programme de la
finale de la Coupe du Monde de 1938
c'est le programme du président de la
République d'alors Albert Lebrun c'est à
noter par Henri Delaunay qui est à
l'origine de la pratique du foot en
France et qui fait partie de ceux qui
ont créé la Coupe du monde de football
sur ce document il y a le programme tout
ce qu'il y a de plus banal un jour de
finale il ne présentation des équipes
remise de la coupe et puis il y a cette
annotation que moi j'ai trouvé drôle
personnellement si le match était nul à
la fin des 90 minutes réglementaires il
se réjouit une prolongation d'une
demi-heure divisée en demi-temps d'un
quart d'heure c'était seulement la
troisième édition de la Coupe du monde
donc il fallait préciser les règles au
président des règles qui finalement
n'ont pas beaucoup bougé n'ont pas
beaucoup changé c'est peut-être ça aussi
la force du foot c'est que ça bouge pas
trop c'est la force et peut-être des
fois l'inconvénient c'est qu'il y a des
sports qui ont des règles qui évoluent
et nous on a beaucoup plus de mal à
faire évoluer les les règles mais là
j'aime bien la formulation quand même
je je sais pas qui l'a écrit mais quand
ils disent si le match était nul
si on comprend bien c'est ça n'a pas plu
le match il est nul il est 0 si le
résultat du score était un match nul
c'est votre chose et il a écrit comme ça
c'est le match était nul on s'est ennuyé
donc on rejoue une demi-heure de plus
pour voir si vous êtes capable de le
faire mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait
besoin de le dire parce que les gens ne
savaient pas avec Henri Delaunay c'est
un autre Français Jules remake qui a
créé la Coupe du monde en 1930 c'est
peut-être aussi pour cela qu'on est un
peu tous les quatre ans presque 68
millions de sélectionneurs c'est aussi
que c'est un peu notre compétition quoi
c'est notre compétition oui c'est vrai
que ça a été c'est parti de France même
la Coupe d'Europe et à toutes les
compétitions sont parties on oublie un
peu
ils savent pas je vais dire que quelque
part les dirigeants les politiques les
sportifs français sont à l'initiative de
toutes ces
ce qui existe maintenant votre passion
pour le foot à vous elle arrive quand
elle arrive à quel moment est-ce que
c'était dans la cité HLM lyonnaise dans
laquelle vous viviez qu'il y avait
guerre autre chose à faire que du
football c'est la base c'est la base on
est quand on vit dans les quartiers
en décembre on est dans la cour on vit
dans la cour on oublie toujours nous on
n'avait pas les portables on n'avait pas
tous les jeux et les électroniques donc
le seul moyen d'avoir du lien avec les
autres c'était il y avait l'école et
puis le reste du temps
on descendait et on joue au foot parce
qu'il y avait pas de place pour autre
chose nous c'était un bout de de terrain
en pelouse qui était même pas carré ni
rectangulaire qui était fait avec des
angles et on arrivait à trouver là et
tout le monde jouait en fait c'est dire
les rangs les petits c'était ça à
l'allure de celui que vous êtes
aujourd'hui quel conseil donneriez-vous
au petit garçon que vous étiez qu'est-ce
que vous lui diriez avant qu'il ne se
lance dans la vie
dans le contexte où j'étais et pas grand
chose d'autre à faire que de se sauver
par soit les études soit par le sport
j'ai essayé de suivre les deux depuis
longtemps possible
il y a que ça le reste c'est pas se
laisser en barquer par
les idées des autres les idées malsaines
souvent ou les facilités qu'on peut
avoir c'est de cela qu'il fallait vous
sauver il faut se sauver de ça dans les
quartiers se sauver de ça il faut sauver
de ça parce qu'il faut avoir un peu de
caractère pour pas se laisser prendre
par la règle de la de la meute et garder
son identité en se disant moi je peux
exister par moi-même j'ai pas besoin de
des règles de cette vie qu'on veut
m'imposer j'ai aussi le droit d'avoir
mes règles de vie et ça c'est important
et je le dis souvent dans tous les
maintenant avec ce que j'ai vécu un
icena qui est
j'ai fait le pont après avec ma vie et
de me dire pour sortir il faut avoir un
petit peu de courage et c'est ce que
n'ont pas eu les joueurs Nice na ils
étaient 23 il y en a aucun qui a eu le
courage de dire c'est une connerie ce
qu'on est en train de faire moi je
descends ils ont été pris par par la
meute la meute et c'est la loi du
quartier aussi et parce que si on sort
et qu'on est différent on est rejeté je
leur dis toujours il vaut mieux être
rejeté et exister par soi-même que
d'être dans la masse de la meute et de
ne rien faire par soi-même si on reprend
votre histoire depuis le début vous êtes
né à Lyon votre mère Germaine était
ouvrière chez Calor d'origine piednois
vous me dites si je me trompe votre père
raymondo était ouvrier dans une fonderie
puis homme d'entretien dans un grand
magasin un catalan militant
anti-franquiste qui trouve refuge en
France lors de la guerre civile
espagnole vous dites à propos de lui il
était du côté des abandonnés ces
républicains que les Français parquet
dans des camps avant de les renvoyer en
Espagne où ils étaient fusillés
heureusement il avait moins de 18 ans il
a échappé au retour forcé vers
l'abattoir et je crois que vous avez
longtemps été en colère après les
autorités françaises et c'est drôle
parce que l'histoire a fait de vous
quelqu'un qui a représenté la France qui
a servi la France il y a un paradoxe
non il y a pas de paradoxe je dis après
moi j'étais levé dans la culture
française mon père a grandi ici on a
bénéficié de de
des infrastructures de la France de les
dieux de l'éducation de la santé de de
tout ça mais quelque part moi j'avais
cette révolte contre l'injustice la
justice déjà des l'Angleterre de
l'Angleterre et de la France et de la
frayeur de ne pas affronter Franco et de
pas défendre la République
en Espagne et de laisser une dictature
ce qui est installée et surtout après
les camps de réfugiés c'est pas une
légende des camps de réfugiés nous
français et je dis bien nous Français
maintenant on en a créé pour parquer les
réfugiés catalans ou autre qui
arrivaient qui était laissé à l'abandon
avec les maladies avec pas de nourriture
c'est une page sombre de l'histoire de
France qu'on oublie on en oublie
quelques-unes d'autres mais voilà dire
ça existait je vais dire on va pas se
faire un rakiri maintenant pour ça mais
ça a existait à ce moment là c'est
intéressant de vous parliez de révolte
parce que je poursuis le fil de votre
histoire mais ça explique aussi un petit
peu la suite à 8 ans vous signez une
licence à l'OL vous êtes doué votre
frère Albert joue aussi il deviendra pro
comme vous mais on dit de vous que vous
avez plus envie que lui que vous avez
plus de hargne plus tard Bernard Lacombe
ancien footballeur international que
vous connaissez très bien et qui vous
connaît depuis très longtemps dit au
centre de formation il se pointait à
l'entraînement avec la voiture de son
père alors qu'il était mineur c'était un
garçon intelligent mais ce côté provoque
rebelle il l'avait déjà il l'a toujours
eu votre caractère fort ira jusqu'à vous
faire louper l'épreuve de philo du bac
parce que l'avant veille je crois vous
jouiez une finale de Coupe de France et
vous l'avez d'ailleurs un peu regretté
vous avez dit c'est mon regret j'aurais
aimé faire du droit de venir avocat un
métier qui peut mener à la présidence de
la République justement on y revient
finalement vous avez été rebelle toute
votre vie vous avez fait des choix
atypiques toute votre vie qui vous qui
faisait de vous quelqu'un à part oui
rebelle mais quand vous dites pour le
bac c'est plutôt de la faiblesse c'était
de la lâcheté c'est de se dire oui
complètement de ne pas y aller c'était
de la facilité j'étais professionnel je
dirais à la limite j'en avais pas besoin
sur le moment je suis gagné ma vie je
gagnais déjà plus que ce gagné mais mes
parents sans avoir le bac j'ai pas senti
la nécessité et c'est là où je regrette
quelque part les centres de formation
parce que maintenant dans les centres de
formation les gamins qui rentrent on les
pousse pour qu'ils aillent au maximum de
leurs capacités que ça soit technique
physique sportive mais intellectuel
aussi celui qui peut avoir le bac quand
il est dans un centre de formation il
aura parce qu'il aura derrière des gens
qui l'encadrait nous on était livrés
nous-mêmes moi j'allais j'allais à
l'entraînement à l'école j'y allais si
j'avais envie c'était c'était ça c'était
la facilité donc
c'est c'est un regret et la rébellion
oui surtout le reste la rébellion dans
le sport oui j'étais un rebelle
permanent tout votre parc je ne
supportais pas de perdre mais c'était
vraiment un truc et j'étais capable de
tout et oui c'est
je crois que ça c'est la culture c'est
ma culture c'est ce que m'a donné dans
les gènes c'est ce que m'a donné mon
père c'est cette rébellion permanente
promis capitaine de l'OL vous êtes l'un
des meneurs de la grève inédite des
footballeurs professionnels en 1972
Jean-Michel Aulas dit de vous Raymond a
la pertinence de la CFDT le sens du
compromis de la CGC il a ses idées il
les défenses est un redoutable débatteur
ainsiducteur aussi qui a une grande
faculté à théâtraliser son action CFDT
CGC moi j'aurais presque dit CGT non
parce que quelque part je suis président
à l'heure actuelle du syndicat des
entraîneurs et on avait lieu on avait le
choix je suis dans le dans le débat
je dirais que la CGT on a l'impression
qu'on est que dans l'opposition et on
peut pas être dans le foot et discuter
avec les gens si on n'est pas dans une
forme de collaboration
c'est un compromis le débat c'est un
compromis et ça je l'ai compris petit à
petit en grandissant au début non
c'était non non oui j'étais CGT même
plus que CGT j'étais plus à gauche que
la gauche j'étais plutôt plus dans
l'anarchie que dans la
corporation et ça aussi c'est mon père
qui me l'a qui m'a inculqué parce que il
était dans les entreprises dans la dans
la fonderie il a toujours refusé des
syndiquer il dit quand on est syndiqué
on est obligé de suivre tous les autres
moi quand j'ai quelque chose à dire je
le dis et jugé j'attends pas que
quelqu'un le dise à ma place et je l'ai
gardé un petit peu cette culture dès le
début votre carrière de footballeur est
parsemé de moments tendu aussi avec le
public avec la presse vous êtes très
vite qualifiés de boucher par les
journalistes à cause d'une faute que
vous n'avez pas commise mon pardon je
l'ai découvert en préparant cette
interview ça se le 12 août 1970 premiers
matchs de la saison Nice Lyon vous venez
d'intégrer l'OL et on vous attribue la
faute qui provoque la fracture tibia
péronée de Helmut Metzler cette faute
c'est un certain Jean Baeza qui va qui
l'aura commise pourquoi ne pas avoir
cherché à rectifier les choses pourquoi
avoir assumé une faute qui n'était pas
la vôtre parce que déjà à l'époque il y
avait pas les réseaux il y avait pas les
images en revoyait pas ce qui s'était
passé c'était c'était compliqué donc
c'était ce qu'on pouvait ce que pouvait
dire les gens ce qu'on pouvait dire nous
et c'était sur les journaux et ça
pouvait être que le lendemain que où on
pouvait rectifier les choses
c'était votre parole contre et à la fin
du match j'ai discuté avec un avec
quelqu'un de l'encadrement de du club
qui était là de temps en temps il me dit
tu sais l'essentiel dans ce métier là
c'est qu'on parle de toi en mal en bien
mais que tu existes et je me suis rendu
compte qu'en fait on avait j'avais fait
un match minable j'étais pas bon
heureusement d'ailleurs qui se blesse
parce que je sais pas si j'aurais fait
une carrière si j'avais fait 1h30 contre
lui je sais pas si j'aurais fait
carrière il était un super joueur et
vous endossez à ce moment-là la vie du
méchant oui je l'endos en me disant au
moins j'ai fait un personnage ça c'est
Guero qui me le dit qui me l'a dit aussi
après il me dit il faut pas il faut pas
essayer chercher à être gentil sympa
autrement dit il faut être il faut avoir
un vrai personnage lui il était celui le
gripsough qui faisait des trucs mais il
le revendiquait et il disait on me
reconnaît on m'identifie comme ça et moi
j'étais le méchant
il fallait que je garde ce rôle là des
gens comprennent pas quand on change de
registre ils aiment bien cataloguer les
gens et dans ce jeu là
je faisais plus peur que mal il y en a
qui était bien plus violent que moi
cette époque là mais eu à une autre
époque encore une fois en plaisantant je
dis toujours si on était arbitré à
l'époque comme on est arbitré maintenant
il y a pas un match qui durait plus d'un
quart d'heure il y aura eu trois trois
joueurs expulsés de chaque côté à chaque
fois c'est c'était permis c'était dans
l'air du temps on pouvait faire on
pouvait faire ça donc oui j'ai endossé
ce personnage de du méchant parce que ça
m'arrangeait bien c'était facile ça
facilité les choses le travail était à
moitié fait avant de commencer le match
alors footballeur entraîneur vous auriez
aimé on l'a dit être président de la
République vous auriez aimé être acteur
aussi vous l'avez été en amateur
notamment avec une compagnie qui
s'appelait le trimard mais être ça vous
a coûté vous souffriez d'un track fou et
vous avez dit un jour le théâtre est une
souffrance je crois qu'il faut être maso
pour aimer ça ça me bouffe c'est l'enfer
mais le plaisir est tellement énorme
quand on l'a fait Raymond Domenech elle
traque on a du mal à l'imaginer quand
même
la première fois que je l'ai fait je
l'ai fait c'était une troupe amateur et
on faisait une représentation c'était à
Lyon où j'avais je m'étais décidé
j'avais commencé à faire du théâtre à
Mulhouse mais j'avais pas fait les
représentations de fin donc on faisait
juste le truc parce que je me suis dit
bon je suis entraîné j'avais pas osé et
à Lyon j'ai
osé et la première pièce qu'on fait
c'était l'ours de Tchekhov donc il y a
un personnage masculin et deux et deux
femmes qui commencent et qui ont un duo
pendant 5 minutes et moi je suis
derrière le rideau avec le la toque sur
la tête la fourrure c'était en ça devait
être au mois de juin juillet il faisait
40 dehors j'étais
en âge et le metteur en scène c'était
une petite salle avait fermé la porte de
derrière parce qu'elle donnait sur une
cour il dit des fois il y a des gens qui
peuvent rentrer donc on ferme la porte à
clé heureusement qu'il a fermé la porte
à clé parce que s'il avait pas fermé la
porte avec les je me serais sauvé je ne
serais même pas rentré quand je me suis
rendu compte que avec le public c'était
une torture
vous avez préféré théâtraliser le foot
voilà où là c'était facile je
connaissais les règles et là la faute
est permise là la faute est permise
parce que on peut tout faire au théâtre
non au théâtre quand on se plante on
embarque tout on embarque tout le monde
et on reste là
la peur du trou noir c'est le truc j'ai
des photos pour vous et mon domicile
dans cette émission
et la première photo la voici c'est
Karim Benzema grand footballeur qui vous
doit sa première sélection en équipe de
France je crois né à Lyon lui aussi et
il a pris un peu tout le monde de cours
en quittant le Real Madrid pour signer
dans un club saoudien il va toucher près
de 200 millions d'euros par an il aurait
tort de se priver
je sais pas
pour répondre à ces questions je
relative toujours et j'essaye de me
mettre à sa place et j'aurais fait quoi
alors qu'est-ce que vous auriez fait je
sais pas c'est vrai honnêtement je sais
pas parce que c'est beau c'est facile de
dire oui mais pour ce qu'il est il
aurait pu rester en Europe il aurait pu
continuer jouer il est parti juste pour
gagner de l'argent
ouais on peut le dire
mais
c'est facile de juger les autres quand
on n'est pas dans la situation après lui
il a peut-être des arguments à sa
décharge le championnat saoudien est en
train et et un des plus construits en
Asie il y avait celui du Japon et
l'Arabie Saoudite et solide il va avoir
des matchs il va y avoir du monde c'est
pas le Qatar c'est pas des stades vides
c'est il y a un vrai engouement ils sont
en train de développer quelque chose des
États-Unis on fait pareil à un moment
Pelé y est allé Beckenbauer est allé
là-bas pour essayer de développer donc
pourquoi pas honnêtement j'aurais
préféré qui viennent une année à Lyon
qui joue encore en Europe parce qu'il a
encore du talent et il a envie non et
après c'est son choix il a des capacités
pour ça mais je juge pas je juge pas
cette situation une deuxième photo les
joueuses de l'équipe de foot féminin la
coupe du monde de foot féminin qui a mis
beaucoup de temps à trouver un diffuseur
en France et un peu partout en Europe
alors que les audiences sont plutôt
bonnes et l'engouement est en train de
se développer autour du foot féminin
vous le regardez vous le foot féminin un
peu je dois avouer que je suis pas je
suis pas tous les matchs mais que tu as
les matchs de l'équipe de France ou de
temps en temps les lions PSG parce que
le niveau est voilà il y a une il y a
une différence le problème c'est à
l'heure actuelle c'est ça c'est
pourquoi vous n'entraînez pas une équipe
de foot féminine j'ai plus l'âge
d'entraîner puis je pense qu'il y a des
jeunes qui sont qui sont faits pour ça
qui sont
c'est un autre métier tous ceux qui ont
entraîné les filles d'ailleurs dans les
formations ils vont mettre des volets
pour l'approche
de la gestion des féminines que ça soit
quelle différence entre entraîner déjà
il y a des problématiques liées à la
féminité qui sont différentes il y a des
problèmes baltiques sur la musculation
ce qui est on a constaté qu'il y avait
beaucoup plus de blessures de de genoux
des croisés qui se faisaient pour les
femmes il y a la gestion
psychologique un groupe de femmes un
groupe d'hommes c'est compliqué mais un
groupe de femmes c'est différent
c'est plus compliqué j'ai dit c'est
différent vous vous sentez pas de le
faire en tout cas je pense que j'aurais
été très bien
oui ben alors mais je suis passé j'ai
quelque part ça m'aurait intéressé pour
pour cette gestion a eu humaine qui est
complètement différente où là la il faut
être beaucoup plus fin dans la gestion
n'arrive pas avec ces grosses sabots en
dedans non parce qu'en plus elles ont
elles ont plus d'exigence que que les
mecs de tous ceux qui l'ont fait ils
disent elles s'intéressent à ce qu'on
leur fait faire elle pose des questions
elles essayent de d'évoluer oui parce
qu'elle part de plus bas et elles ont
besoin de justification donc elles ont
envie d'apprendre beaucoup plus et ça
c'est intéressant quand on est
entraîneur les mecs qui viennent vous
être attrapés les mecs qui viennent on
leur fait faire n'importe quoi ils font
ils s'en foutent il y a le match avec
les femmes c'est pas pareil j'ai une
dernière question qui est en lien avec
ce lieu Raymond Domenech nous sommes
entourés de quatre statues que vous avez
remarqué juste avant l'émission chacune
représente une vertu il y a la sagesse
la prudence la justice et derrière moi
l'éloquence laquelle de ces vertus vous
parlent le plus pour moi vous l'avez
compris quelque part c'est à l'opposé de
l'injustice c'est la justice c'est de se
dire que voilà
l'injustice et la pire des choses c'est
l'injustice à tous les niveaux
d'ailleurs on en a pas parlé je fais
partie d'un collectif qui s'appelle
collectif contre les discriminations ou
c'est l'injustice de la vie des uns et
des autres notamment les enfants malades
où on travaille avec le cartable
connecté pour aider des enfants qui sont
à l'hôpital à avoir une scolarité à peu
près normale donc oui c'est de
l'injustice donc pour moi la valeur qui
qui compte le plus c'est
c'est la justice et bien ce sera le mot
de la fin merci merci infiniment et mon
domaine d'avoir joué le jeu de toutes
ces questions et de toutes ces rituels
merci d'avoir été avec nous et merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis comme chaque
semaine à très vite sur Public Sénat
merci
[Musique]